you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens hey everybody welcome out
to GameSpot's co-op stage live from e3
2016 hey i'm chad from ScrewAttack and I
got Danny here and also we're very
special guest hello Norman Reedus and is
dead we're digital baby are gonna hang
out with us today as we I guess ranked
Microsoft right exactly we're gonna be
ranking our excitement for microsoft's
press conference and just talking about
all the stuff cuz they went in a ballsy
move uh this year so uh first of all
right out of the gate they announced the
xbox one s yes I mean there's one of
many things that leaks before but
beforehand that's it it always happens i
guess it seemed like a lot of this stuff
on Microsoft's top morning whatever was
going on and we learn a lot about it but
yes yes it sits at the same price as the
regular one when it's 99 99 it's like
ridiculously smaller which is a big deal
especially because not only do they make
it smaller but they also incorporated an
internal power supply right so for the
people who don't know what that means
that means that gigantic brick that
you've had like just getting in the way
everywhere big well it's gone it's just
gonna be a cable now did you want an
Xbox one right yeah yeah I got one at
lunch and I did not realize how big that
like it reminded me of the original xbox
it oh holy [ __ ] where am I gonna put
this thing yeah yeah so I'm very happy
about that I've we are ranking them
right yeah yeah yeah I'd love to see
what you're actually a triangle yes but
what I've done is I've drawn the xbox
one and I've draw have you seen in this
circle yes on this so there's a problem
whenever they show it on all like the
pictures of the xbox one s it's this
really nice finished grid but if you
actually see it up front it's got this
massive black hole in it which is like
none of the key art shows but if you see
it in real life it's like this awful
awesome black hole no i think is the
black hole for you so I don't know like
I think it looks cool it's nice and why
you remember when they zoom in that's
where the games are they filling the
holes it's a game this is this the holy
heart where xbox one was meant to be
this whole time and we'll talk about
this here in a little bit but they did
something at the end of the press
conference so the announcing scorpio
that I think is just huge
mistake for the s like I think the only
reason it's it's just going to exist for
people who buy one right now they'll
just get an S like I don't think anybody
like anyone who got excited about the s
right when they first talked about it
it's like okay yeah I'm gonna go buy it
and then they now scorpion like oh never
mind yeah I mean it's so far away that
of like I don't you're right it's like
anyone are there lots are there jobs of
people who are waiting for an excuse to
buy an xbox like I don't know that they
are and if they are you've just told
them to wait another 18 months so i
guess like maybe it just buys them
sometime it's like hey this is a new
form factor maybe the components got
cheaper to like make this new version
than the old one yeah the scorpio looks
interesting there you know talking about
this sixth teraflops thing I'm not
really sure you know that they're
talking about what was it and limited
like HD 4k gaming 4k that was the big
thing that if you want a two hundred
ninety nine dollar for cave player there
you go you can get the xbox one s yeah
right anything Norman and then none
Norman likes my ID so I thank you I
tried to draw scorpion Scorpio scorp
from Marla calm my looks like a dr
aycott is the opposite of a dog yeah
well known maybe he's like repenting his
ways and now he just got a sweet little
head over here I've got your medication
sorry i don't know i think you're right
it's weird that they I mean if they
don't ever know what Sony's gonna do it
was like regular saying in a lot yeah
they so I can first every time I have to
come out and say look this is all the
stuff for doing for next two years I'm
guessing we'll see a lot more of a next
year a Scorpio and I just hope it's as
powerful as what they're saying because
like who knows it's all p artist had six
teraflops six they're gonna stress that
does everyone know I've know a mascara
bar it's not gonna move to America and I
had to go back two miles yeah [ __ ]
remember miles are I lived in Ireland
we'd miles and in Europe was like no
kilometers how many how many kilometers
would you give the score via six dr.
Scorpio is faux PA dr. Scorpio hello dr.
Scorpio there's a trusting family name
everybody wants to go to dr. scores on
Obamacare yeah nope we'll see um so the
next one I want to talk about and this
one is one that I'm super high for and
they did a really interesting trailer
and that's we happy few rice so really
creepy first of all it starts out in the
dude's just sitting there and he's
like changing his little newspaper
clippings and all of a sudden he sees a
picture of Harry Potter who's won a
sorting contest and maybe it's a sorting
hat ah but yeah so he sees that and he
starts freaking out and I'm like wow
that was a pretty strong reaction that
he might thinks about taking his pill
right and then ye pale yeah have a joy
filled the lady comes in with a painted
face and just you know she's like hey
come with me we need you we're gonna
have a pinata in the meeting room so you
go in there and he starts tripping out
and you see like you've already got this
like really creepy vibe yeah but in this
kind of happy environment so I'm already
just like hook line and sinker into the
game you know like seeing what's going
on and then you know they're bash in
this pinata and I'm like I hear that
like squishing sounds and I'm like oh no
this is gonna be a real thing I was like
don't be a dog so like luckily it was a
wrong but really cool so what about you
what are you thinking about I've drawn
it a paint it's supposed to be a paint
brush with a new lick of paint because I
played this game a bunch I played it I
gamescom in Germany Lionel here galati
but i'll just write my name on it I'll
do Donny cuz everyone always says Donnie
because of my stupid Irish accent and
yeah so I played this game for about 40
minutes at Gamescom and it's I've ever
played sir you are being hunted No so
it's this PC like sort of open worlds
sandbox procedurally generated thing
where there are like different biomes
and you're you're being hunted by all
these robots right and we happy few is
kind of like that where it's to budget
from biomes one is like the big rich
city we're all like the people who pop
their joy pills right and then there's a
kind of like destitute one across the
river which is where all like the people
who are all dour and don't take their
joy kind of like Hunger Games e la right
and it's in this weird sort of like 1984
future London so it's watching this was
interesting because this basically looks
like the first five minutes of a game
that is otherwise actually like not a
linear you know story-driven Bioshock
thing but actually kind of a sandbox see
things so that's kind of interesting
because I'm wondering are they kind of
like is there a bait-and-switch
happening for people who haven't seen
the old games but also just in terms of
Nixon pain it looks way better than it
did before yeah look like an indie PC
thing before I that's fine but like now
it looks like a triple-a like
first-person game now oh no it's it's
definitely got my interest
it's I want to see more of it but it
looks it definitely has the charm needed
nowadays especially in the industry you
know to get your attention you know a
unique-looking it's like your clockwork
orangey exactly that's right with its
kind of Clockwork Orange adventure I get
her ving yeah let's just hope nobody's
gonna be killing anyone with a giant not
gonna say it yeah I like it I could say
this is your thing like it I can't touch
me that's how I was gonna draw alright
cool so next up we had a gears for right
hmm what do you feel they are you a big
fan of the gears franchise I am I liked
them I played the multiplayer beta a
couple months back and they you know it
felt like Gears of War which is what I
thought I wanted but it turns out i
might be pasta i don't know i think what
gears there's an interesting problem
they have we're like they're not they're
trying to like give it I got a new like
a pain but it's so familiar to the old
gears games and I don't know what the
new thing is it's like trying to drag me
back in it and they say they're going
back to like the horror roots and there
was an element of like the first gears
of war game with especially with some of
the boss fights and the krill levels of
their it was a bit more scary than two
and three which were just like all their
bombast but again I don't know it's just
that the level they showed was like a
turrets firing at you and then you go
press exit the thing and the tour stops
missing it nothing about it like in a
demo with like all of these really cool
games gears just felt like just kind of
lukewarm yeah I'm getting away the key
hey here's four out of ten gears for
said perfect sorry I'm sorry kieres
Viking just I did probably a good game
in there but you know what i owe it to
us you know what I was more excited
about gears related what the
announcement of general wrong in killer
interesting yeah which we're gonna have
them on here a little bit later today
and when they talk to the guy yeah yeah
I'm a big fighting game player right
they did a really good job with killer
instinct so Jenna rom is like the most
annoying part of gears of war one like
that jerk on the train with it like the
tiny area till I kill him yeah oh yeah
yeah we're actually gonna have an galaxy
on here later today I will be showing
off general Rahm and all that good stuff
so I got to play him earlier I'm gonna
save my opinions for but I got really
excited
yeah we'll get to that a little bit and
then oh man best introduction to a game
ever I love this guy he comes out there
and he's just so you could tell he's
like a little nervous he's just like for
me gaming it's all about getting to live
your dreams and I've always dreamed of
playing in a world with dragons and then
it's just like scalebound you know we
got the whole thing it was like all
right you know I'm not even gonna hate
on the dude that's like the most honest
developer ever out there right usually
it's all you know buzz words and get
mechanics like I just want to play with
dragons right who doesn't want to play
with dragons dragons are cool so uh yeah
they didn't out scalebound it looks
really really interesting uh and then
you got your giant anomie crap right
2016 it was like totally lost on me it
wasn't till like two hours later
somebody said that I was like oh yeah
yeah yeah I mean they showed off what
the role of the Dragon is which i think
is something that they showed a bunch of
game play again at Gamescom last year
and you were kind of like okay it's like
a hack and slash but then you know
you're fighting these big enemies but
then the Dragons just kind of like also
helping out yeah so which is weird
because like a lot of the whole
excitement of taking on big enemies as
always the fact that you're small and
you have to do like piece by piece right
so when you have the drag and it's like
well he's just like helping it so I
think with this demo the good thing they
did was show like the scale of how big
they're actually going that like oh you
know you need the dragon but you still
have that element of you fighting this
big massive thing yeah they're gonna mix
it at the same time like why would you
ever get off of your dragon right I'm
sure they'll come up with convenient
ways they're like the dragon get away so
no dragons allowed miss party jam this
is a no dragon sign sorry I gotta go
fight the crab without you so they're
pushing the whole four player thing a
lot as well you know I feel like that
was III two years back where every
single game especially the Ubisoft games
were like coop coop coop play with your
buddies and my biggest problem with it
is jerk protagonist I just can't get on
board with that guy I don't like him at
all yeah and that was the thing to you
like normally if you're gonna get a game
with dragons it's you know they kind of
go the medieval route or at least
something like that but that's like
Final Fantasy esque like look at our
trendy the guy is and he's like oh I
gotta fight this crab we pop on my
headphone there so and that's what's
turning you off about it is
recently I went back and played sunset
overdrive yeah which is a game that I
never played originally because I didn't
like the marketing but then I play the
game and I was like oh no no no it was
the marketing that was wrong and the
demos it was when I actually played the
game it's like oh they totally got the
tone oh yeah part of me is kind of
thinking maybe I'm being a bit rough on
scale bands well that's good most people
don't even you look maybe I could be
wrong most people don't don't do that
hey Dee talking about video games long
enough you realize that you're like doom
was the biggest like oh no I was totally
wrong about this ever so world you're
wrong a lot of the time so vo man
speaking about forgetting about things
when recore come on I was like a sir
planing I'm like what's oh yeah it's
like that Robo dog game that i forgot
about and like now they start showing
every court like not to hate on it I
looked interesting but I just for some
reason completely forgot about reading
or until they showed it off and what's
really interesting to me is I got to go
because they have it out on the floor
right and I don't know why the way
they're presenting it it's much more
like bright and colorful like I was
watching people play and it's like
lasers and there are really bright and
explosions and lots of color and like I
just kind of got this kind of Wasteland
II vibe from the way they've been
marketing it but it doesn't look like
that at all cool so yeah I'm looking
forward to seeing more of this it was
good that the show gameplay like last
year they had that sort of tone trailer
thing and nobody really knew like these
weird orbs that go into different robots
like if if that's like the personality
that's being shifted into different like
things whatever at least we saw
mechanically how like mac and all these
other robots kind of work my one worry i
guess with this is my baby's not worried
but like k Jaden fuuny last year came
out with you know where mighty number
nine is like almost there it was like a
month away or something and then they
also showed this like mighty number nine
I think it's coming out in two weeks
time yep so that's been a bit of a
nightmare I know he is not responsible
of the development of this he's more of
like sort of creative input or why not
mmm so I just kind of it was good to see
gameplay and I hope that this game is
not going to be like another this is
coming in two years and we were sick of
it by the time yeah and then they can
release that awesome trailer where they
insult their fan base and have pizza
explosions right yeah all over again
alright we're almost out of time so I'm
going to try and fire some these off so
cool huh I love the the presentation of
we're bringing all these requested new
features to the xbox one ya like being
able to listen to music while you play
games like no that was an old feature
that you removed and they did a lot of
that so we have like they're doing the
groups and they're putting a big thing
on the like the group competition like
that kind of stuffs up making clubs yeah
yeah here's a club about people who like
we than ICP there you go correct here's
who's not gonna join that here's the
corn club here's the people who live in
Scotland but also love hatsune miku yeah
there you go I hope I mean Sony did this
couple months back it's been kind of
cool like I'm on a bunch of them on all
goods giant bomb one the kind of funny
one all that's herself so yeah it's good
suck a good rating but they were looking
for group feature which I mean games
like destiny really needs so right
definitely and that's thing to you at
least they acknowledged like so some
people are saying it's really hard for
you to find your friends like yeah
that's because you're you eyes kind of
all over the place so they've already
addressed that one so hopefully it'll
make things a little bit easier we had
gwent the Wicked Game so we'll see it
looks so much like hearthstone like the
layout and everything for that I was
checking it out there like its people
been really enjoying this like yeah it's
probably cuz you've made it a lot like
hearthstone really I like hearthstone
say yes I like this it's a weird game it
was made I was talking to the guy who
made it for Witcher 3 upstairs earlier
and it was made in like a weekend where
apparently they I would sourced a bunch
of really company is to be like okay
make the mini game because he was up
dice poker in which or two yeah then
they couldn't make they didn't get one
of his good so then they went they had a
weekend to make it so this dude and his
body went home made went over the
weekend came in on Monday and we're like
this is it they were like okay put it in
that's all today and then now it's it's
own game that's great crazy had it be
out there so I don't know I'm on the
card game of some so I don't really play
them yeah so yeah I enjoyed it in which
are mostly because it was like you're
talking to the bloody baron you're like
I'm really sorry that your wife and
daughter have been captured by witches
do you want to play some [ __ ] gwen ha
ha and also if i go rescue them I'm
gonna get a new card from my deck okay
that's why I'm really doing it yeah
that's what come on we all know what
should be on those cards it shouldn't be
anything but just like your conquests
this is a game we had a tekken 7 reveal
which not interesting in left they
showed him fighting Akuma
for almost the entire time nice so maybe
just trying to you know the street
fighter cross tekken people are
attacking cross nike cross street
fighter oh please give us that i was
talking to the developers upstairs
better yesterday and they were saying if
this one hopefully does well you know
maybe i get back to it but apparently I
didn't realize this so the arcade
versions been out for like almost a year
now in Japan apparently that helps fund
the console ones no really makes so much
money off the even in Japan's like dying
arcades like they make so much money off
the arcade systems that it helps fund
the console versions yeah so that sort
of shows you where I mean where tech n
is at the moment so hopefully this one
sells and we'll get back to second cross
see any anything fighting game on move
care of selling in a weird place right
now those old yeah SFI SFI like you like
it right yeah it's fun the good it's a
really good fight like more than four
right it's just that all the stuff
surrounding it has been haphazard so
yeah I mean hopefully next year we're
talking to metod know they're about to
roll out this big updates where we get a
story mood and all that I yeah so well
then let's see we had oh I loved this is
their big gimmick Microsoft always has
their press conference gimmick right
whether you're wearing laser shoulder
pads or whatever this was they're gonna
make it snow in conference and so they
revealed dead rising 40 right with these
know in the in the rabbit had it really
knows and they did I love the trailer
for dead rising for tons of personality
we saw like a triceratops shooting fire
yeah and just all sorts of just wacky
insanity Frank West is back thanks back
it's in well amesh it has to act break
his back and I know right he's a
photojournalist now taking selfies of
himself and the mall is in it apparently
the surrounding town of Willow medicine
as well I'm it's this is weird right
because like they are very firmly
planted in the ridiculous you know
zombie action mode I was asking to
developers yesterday whether or not
they're bringing back any of the time
constraints stuff comes in one or the
Zombrex off that was into and neither of
those are gonna be in it and I think a
lot of people missed those from dead
rising 3 but the developer said that
like apparently most people they hate
having the time constraints so that they
were like listening to feedback and that
was like a big sort of push for them so
I don't know like it's weird I really
like that rising it's incredible this is
coming out already this year holiday
yeah but then there was another one
Tony showed I keep forgetting the name
of it the game yeah I days gone days
gone yeah I keep going to until don't
also call it interests gone yeah it
right seems that it's like here so
that's weird maybe that's gonna hijack
some of the hype for that I don't know
but we'll see I think that rises a clear
winner we had see if thieves state of
decay two and halo wars too man
beautiful trailer for Halo Wars i'm not
i don't know i used to love art CSS
growing up like I played Warcraft
Starcraft all that stuff and of course
command and conquer but then like I
don't know I just stopped I just don't
care about RCS anymore very much like
halo war look halo wars to look really
pretty and they had a really that like
kind of melodic kind of entry and I like
the way they did the trailer let's how
you show off a real-time strategy game
yeah because otherwise it's like 15
minutes of isometric a play which is
like do not play well on a stunning show
for stroke the rocket that's how you
showed up I mean I don't know if there
was a massive amount of people screaming
at for this in particular but sure go
for it i mean the first one was
interesting they were trying to bring
real time strategy games to consoles
yeah it found its audience so you know
we'll see it's it's not coming out for
until like you want up next year so well
I hopefully will see more of it soon
yeah and see if the is you get to be a
pirate that looks cool explora it does I
was already talking that I could you a
Michael Dombey on me from easy and he's
like I just want to find ways to screw
over people like you like let's go
explore this island and then destroy the
ship and craft a weapon out of it be
like look at my weapon guys that was not
here forever just hope a bunch of
gunpowder in the hall and was watching
it sink was like the coolest thing oh
yeah like that was that reminded me of
playing like on boats when i was a kid i
said i grew up aside like the Irish like
water freezing water we'd like getting
votes and like play pirates with each
other yeah it was like literally look
the exact same so I was into a bit the
exact same wood at the risk of actual
death which we had back home so yeah it
looks cool I want to know what the
metagame or an today's are you like
trying to get somewhere like no man sky
is it just it seems very open world that
you can just kind of play around and be
pirates and start you know ship battles
with other people hopefully the focus
isn't just the combat hopefully it's
about also like discovery story with it
like sid meier's pirates right exactly
yeah yeah he go cool all right um well
man that was there's a lot at Microsoft
actually think I did a really good job
we've
other press conferences where we kind of
just like where's the games Microsoft
you know or like they patted out with
other developers stuff I'm like I think
they did or they honestly did a really
solid job I walked away from that just
being like wow that was a good
conference weird of them so just like
double console drop us yeah but other
than that they showed off a lot of games
i think i had a really solid conference
and then you know Sony right after just
like crushed it they barely spent any
time I know I'd see them in a way of
things when they come second yeah I
think expectation for Microsoft this
year was kind of like tempers people
weren't expecting to too much yeah and i
think they reach that and a little bit
above it wasn't like some crazy amazing
press conference but it was also very
solid it's been much worse than years
past for sure well lot to get stuff on
the horizon a lot of great games that i
want to play so well alright guys thank
you for joining us for this part or
Microsoft recap for the gamespot co-op
stage here at e3 2016 and of course
Norman man I feel like we barely talked
to Norman I feel bad oh yeah guys tune
back in here in just a few and we'll be
going over nintendo's press conference
which is pretty much Zelda and some
Pokemon thrown in there alright thanks
guys we'll see you soon